an idea that we've floated around is
to hit me with brutal NE negative
comments and uh I will respond have you
still been pretty good on not looking at
comments I'm really good okay I'm really
so these are these are going to be the
first time you hearing these where did
you pull these off of the main channel
the the podcast YouTube channel okay
yeah I I like I un scheduled the last
YouTube video the one of the stunts I
regret just because the promo was just
like I mean it was comically like heavy
like you know and again go to sto.com
and buy merch like but I was sensitive
about that I do I do not want to look at
the comments on that video cuz they're
just going to be like mad at me for
promoting the merch
yeah okay so like I mean it's not like
there are like the meanest comments ever
that even exists I was looking for mean
ones like there's a lot that make fun of
your voice right there was a lot of
negativity on the Zach ass podcast okay
which we have addressed but this one
stuck out so you couldn't just give the
guy a question instead just Grill him
and then bring someone else on to steal
the spotlight Vinnie which was our
friend Vinnie my so that uh yeah I mean
we addressed that yeah okay wow I'm just
telling you what I'm reading did did you
go to that podcast to find that I looked
there's not there's not uh comments
about the Zach podcast living on on a
different episode no no people forget
about it pretty quickly comments on that
podcast okay I mean honestly this is
going to be a little anticlimactic none
of them are like so bad that it's like
funny or really going to hurt your
feelings I think the ones that that are
are relative to this would be like on
the BAM podcast like you're taking
advantage of bam you know using him to
make money but it's like there'll be a
million of those comments on this
podcast just because we're talking about
bam yeah so here's one on the BAM the
one where Bam's not on the podcast you
guys are talking about bam so he's like
in the title and thumb na thumbnail
thumb naal thumb na steo acts like he's
your friend and then he makes a public
video to all his fans public talking
about your meth abuse bro I did not call
him a methodic I said it was alleged
alleged yeah
so yeah people you know feel like you
whatever I mean what do you think like
yeah what what are you g to do man I've
done everything in my power to be the
best bro for bam I mean even even like
uh with the whole board thing it's like
he didn't want to do it it's like okay
well we're going to set up a trust for
your kid we'll donate all the or give
all the money to to Phoenix right is
still a no even Alon payments right or
like child support pay I was like you
know what you're going to get nailed
with uh the courts for alony child
support anyway just like put put this
aside from that like it it would all
that's coming out of your pocket anyway
so let's just uh divert some money to
that and and the suggestion was so
offensive that's the last time I spoke
with bam I think that he was mad at that
yeah how dare you what was his response
to that like how he was so drunk dude
how dare
you he kind of wasn't getting it okay
your podcast with wean has a lot of
negative comments actually because you
took a hard stance against video game
in that podcast and The Gamers spoke up
so this one came from Jim sin 2506 he
said steo you're awesome but if your
analogy about video games is correct are
we just wasting our time watching your
podcast almost all of your fans play
games if you think like that then
everything is a waste of time if you're
not making money out of it yeah the
gamers is a big Community dude I'm a
gamer myself as Call of Duty guy I will
God's a soldier
I I will give that to him and I thought
that that was very uh constructively
worded it wasn't an attack it was like
Hey you know yeah and and and and and
hey man if people enjoy video games have
at it you know I I wild away time
watching stupid Netflix Scott you
haven't always been a gamer right no I
mean I used to play video games when I
was a kid but then I just needed an
outlet to like not look at my phone for
an hour and it's done a really good job
to like where I would just forget about
time there's a lot ofit what are you
guys laughing at over there what that
you're just trying to get you trying to
get your eyes away from a screen so you
go to the TV no not the screen my work
emails cuz I can't turn it off emails so
it's like the work emails it's like
there's no turning off me so if I'm
sitting there watching TV I'm looking at
it but if I'm playing Call of Duty
Modern Warfare 2 you're in the zone I'm
in the zone he's cutting down on screen
time yeah know it's not about cutting
down I mean everywhere you look I mean
I'm looking at screens or you know I
think that's just the reality of life
now you're just you're looking at
screens everywhere you go yeah so yeah I
feel like people have every right to
waste their time however they want and
like some people do spend too much time
playing video games and it does have a
negative effect same as Netflix same as
YouTube same as right porn same as
everything probably most people have a
pretty healthy relationship with and
just do it for fun I'm a super phone
addict dude MH like uh what are you
doing on your phone I mean I don't know
like just stupid Instagram like whatever
I could be way more productive if I uh
had boundaries around my screen time on
my phone when you're looking at
Instagram are you looking at what other
people do or are you looking at like how
your stuff is
doing uh probably mostly that yeah do
you think you have an unhealthy
relationship with Instagram and Social
Media stuff yeah yeah I'm yeah like
Instagram for you is probably not a
healthy door to open you like hate it
but like you can't look away you know
what I mean are there any sort of
programs for like I'm sure video games
or Internet for sure they have like
video game rehab and stuff really yeah
but are are you are you really telling
me that there's not more like a
vitriolic hate why is it that every time
I go into a comment section I end up
with my feelings hurt I don't know maybe
you should have pulled these because I
think back in the day like people were
just like you know Steve's talking over
the guest but like those have kind of
stopped and I think most of like the
hate comments are like all the ads and
Bam but that's I I've never really seen
yeah people hate on the ads but it's
like bro how what what do you we're
trying to make money like how do you
think we're doing this yeah people
hating on the ads just don't I think
it's people hating on the ads don't pay
for YouTube so they have to see our ads
and then the [__] ads that you get
when you don't pay for a subscription on
YouTube don't we um have no mid roll ads
on the podcast no it's just our own ads
like yeah there's no mid roll there's no
literally the
anybody who's hating on the ad reads for
the podcast like they're they're
probably like fans of mine who don't
listen to other podcasts and don't
understand that that's every podcast in
the world yeah that makes sense
sometimes more we only have three like
some some he like six but can't they
just fast forward and don't you have the
bookmarks now uh yeah yeah yeah now yeah
and now it's on YouTube at least it's
how many comments s i just did it so
this is a great cut to be like speaking
of ads have you heard of that and um I
was going to say how many comments are
there like uh telling me that I'm better
at not speaking over my guest but right
when I said that I I spoke right over
well that's stupid [__] um there was
one I pulled on the Steve Oki podcast
someone wrote like steo actually shut up
on this one and we got to hear the guest
talk and there are times where you like
I do see those comments but see the
thing is with with pulling these
comments is like it's either stuff we've
already talked about like bam or Zach or
the fact that you talk over your guests
or the video game stuff like no one's
like no one's like you like you know oh
steo and his whatever no one's talking
[__] on your skateboarding didn't get
that offensive yeah yeah I mean you
could pull up a comment right now see if
you see any you don't like I I'm not I'm
not worried about it do you like
shopping on Amazon I do and good news is
sto's butt wipes for your butthole are
available on Amazon and if you want a
real bundle of a deal you can get sto's
hot sauce fre your butthole plus sto's
butthole destroyer and steo butt wipes
for your butthole it's the butt hole
bundle available on Amazon right
now yeah dude